nationalism and globalism okay we've
talked about nationalism and globalism
we've talked about issues going on on
our planet currently that don't lend
themselves to nationalist solutions
we'll get to that again a little bit
later in this segment but the context is
that Donald Trump has been acutely
anti-globalist anti-globalist he's been
a nationalist nationalist typically want
protectionist economic policies tariffs
border walls etc globalists tend to be
more supportive of free movement of
people free movement of capital free
trade less strict immigration policies
no border walls looking at Trump's
policy ideas over the campaign it's been
pretty clear where he stands he wants a
border wall he's a nationalist get out
of NAFTA he backed out on that he wants
to you know he's talking negatively
about the global power structure that
Rob's our working class that's all
nationalist rhetoric but lately there
have been some splits on the global as
globalism nationalism issue Steve Bannon
and Trump's wacky spokesperson Steven
Miller are more on the nationalist side
but then you've got people like Jared
Kushner and Reince Priebus who are more
globalist in their thinking so Trump was
asked about that split in an interview
with The Wall Street Journal a few days
ago and Trump basically dismissed the
idea with something that I read it must
be 50 times now Pat and I can't figure
it out
Trump said hey I'm a nationalist and a
globalist I'm both and I'm the only one
who makes the decision believe me is
this some kind of record like a hundred
and eighty degree flip-flop in the same
sentence within two words of each other
I just don't think that he realizes some
things are mutually exclusive so for
example you can't be a communist and a
laissez-faire capitalist at the same
time you can't be authoritarian and
libertarian this is one of those things
or can you be both apparently in Trump's
mind you can I don't know does anybody
think that Trump just doesn't really
understand the meaning of either
globalist or nationalists I mean that
that's probably the simplest explanation
here because what I'm hearing when Trump
says I'm both a national
and a globalist is I don't really know
what either term means for my politics
and I'd rather not commit to anything in
particular so I'll just say I'm both and
hopefully appeal to everybody and
remember when flip-flopping used to take
take a candidate down so for example
Mitt Romney and John Kerry
yeah probably lost their respective
races because they change their mind on
these issues Trump does it with every
single issue down the board yeah there's
no issue where Trump has really been
totally consistent you know that silly
phrase it's something like it's a riddle
wrapped in a mystery inside of an enigma
or something like that have you ever
heard that before
yes this from Trump is ignorance wrapped
in confusion within delusions of
grandeur that's how I would summarize
I'm both a globalist and a nationalist
it's kind of getting to a point where
the irony and the contradictions kind of
lose their effect because that is what
is expected at this point right the term
globalism goes back to the 40s do you
think Trump's knows that though the term
nationalism as a concept goes back
further about the late 1700s onward
ranging across many countries when we
talk about an issue like climate change
and I've said this before we're not
going to find a nationalist solution to
climate change pollution does not
respect imaginary lines drawn on a map
we need global of solutions and I'm not
talking about globalist in the sense of
Alex Jones you know global ish I'm
talking about just a globalist solution
that spans more than one country
unemployment technological unemployment
and automation we need a globalist
solution not globalist in the sense of a
new world order one world government the
likes of which you would hear on
Infowars but one in which Trump can't
act unilaterally to solve that problem
and I think that this is just a
fundamental problem
it goes beyond Trump specifically this
is just a fundamental problem with the
types of solutions most of which aren't
actually solutions that we've heard
proposed from Donald Trump